>> Sean: THIS IS A FOX NEWS
ALERT ON THIS FRIDAY NIGHT
BIG BOMBSHELL NEWS.
THE BUZZFEED SO-CALLED
BOMBSHELL YOU HAVE BEEN
HEARING ABOUT ALL DAY IT IS
A DUD.
IT IS A FRAUD.
IT IS A LIE IT IS ALL FAKE
NEWS.
SO THE PROFESSIONAL TRUMP
HATERS AND THE FAKE NEWS
MEDIA THEY HAVE YET DONE IT
AGAIN.
AND EARLIER TODAY BUZZFEED
NEWS REPORTED A SALACIOUS
STORY ABOUT MICHAEL COHEN
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP ALLEGING
THAT COHEN BRIEFED TRUMP
ABOUT A BUILDING PROJECT IN
MOSCOW NUMEROUS TIMES AND
THAT THE PRESIDENT DIRECTED
MICHAEL COHEN TO LIE ABOUT
THE EXISTENCE OF THAT
PROJECT WHEN IT ALREADY HAD
BEEN WELL-KNOWN.
THE STORY ALLEGEDLY SOURCED
TWO ANONYMOUS FEDERAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS.
AS IT TURNS OUT THIS REPORT
WAS TOTAL FAKE NEWS.
EVERYONE AT BUZZFEED SHOULD
BE ASHAMED OF THEMSELVES.
SPECIAL COUNSEL'S OFFICE
ISSUED A STATEMENT THEY
WROTE BUZZFEED'S DESCRIPTION
OF SPECIFIC STATEMENTS TO
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL'S OFFICE
AND CHARACTERIZATION OF
DOCUMENTS AND TESTIMONY
OBTAINED BY THIS OFFICE,
REGARDING MICHAEL COHEN'S
CONGRESSIONAL TESTIMONY ARE
NOT ACCURATE.
BUT ARE WE REALLY SURPRISED?
OH, AND IT EVEN GETS BETTER.
THE EDITOR AND CHIEF OF
BUZZFEED IS ACTUALLY
STANDING BY THE REPORTING,
WHICH THE FBI, THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL COMPLETELY REFUTES.
WATCH THIS.
>> THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
ISSUED THIS VERY BIG
STATEMENT.
WE ARE HERE KNOW WHAT YOU
ARE TALKING ABOUT.
>> DO YOU STAND BY THE
REPORTING THAT YOU GUYS
PUBLISHED WHICH IS, YOU
KNOW, A SCOOP THAT NO ONE
ELSE HAS OR HAS NOT
CONFIRMED.
>> YES.
AS WE WROTE, WE HAVE TWO
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIALS, NO GAME PLAYING
WITH THOSE TITLES WHO HAVE
TOLD THAT'S PRESIDENT TRUMP
DIRECTED MICHAEL COHEN TO
LIE TO CONGRESS ABOUT
NEGOTIATIONS TO BUILD THE
TRUMP TOWER IN MOSCOW.
>> Sean: A BOLD STANCE FROM
ONE OF THE LEADERS IN FAKE
NEWS AND IT GETS EVEN WORSE.
REMEMBER, THIS IS THE SAME
BUZZFEED NEWS, SUPPOSEDLY,
THAT PUBLISHED THE PHONY
HILLARY CLINTON BOUGHT AND
PAID FOR STEELE RUSSIAN
DOSSIER AND THEY NEVER EVER
TRIED TO ROBERT ANY OF THE
DETAILS.
AND GUESS WHAT?
THE LATEST DEVASTATING
REPORT CONTAINED NO DIRECT
CORROBORATION.
ISTIC WATCHING THIS ALL DAY.
AND ONE OF THE BUZZFEED
REPORTERS THAT BROKE THE
STORY EVEN ADMITTED HE NEVER
ACTUALLY SAW THE EVIDENCE
THAT WERE REFERENCED BY HIS
ANONYMOUS SOURCES.
WATCH THIS.
>> YOU HAVE TWO LAW
ENFORCEMENT SOURCES THAT
TELL YOU THAT THEY HAVE SEEN
EVIDENCE.
HAVE YOU SEEN ANY OF THAT
OTHER CORROBORATING
EVIDENCE?
>> NO, NOT SEEN IT
PERSONALLY BUT THE FOLKS
THAT WE HAVE TALKED TO.
THE TWO OFFICIALS WE SPOKE
TO ARE FULLY 100 PERCENT
READ IN.
>> Sean: TWO REPORTERS FOR
BUZZFEED.
THE OTHER REPORTER,
RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS STORY
IS A GUY BY THE NAME OF
JASON LEOPOLD.
HE ACTUALLY CONTRADICTS HIS
CO-AUTHOR.
WATCH THIS.
>> NOW, YOUR COLLEAGUE, WHO
YOU WROTE THE STORY WITH
SAYS THAT NEITHER OF YOU,
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THOSE
DOCUMENTS THAT YOU GUYS
HAVEN'T ACTUALLY SEEN THEM.
YOU HAVEN'T SEEN THE
DOCUMENTS, THE TEXTS, ET
CETERA.
HOW CONFIDENT ARE YOU THAT
THESE ACTUALLY EXIST THAT
THIS IS TRUE.
>> I DON'T THINK THAT WE
HAVE SAID WE HAVEN'T SEEN
THEM AND WE HAVE BEEN -- I
WILL JUST SAY THAT WE HAVE
SEEN DOCUMENTS.
WE HAVE BEEN BRIEFED ON
DOCUMENTS.
WE ARE VERY CONFIDENT.
>> Sean: YOU THINK THAT THE
TWO AUTHORS COULD GET THEIR
STORY STRAIGHT BEFORE
APPEARING ON NATIONAL TV?
THIS WAS KNOWN EARLIER IN
THE DAY.
NOW GETTING STORIES RIGHT IS
NOT A STRENGTH OF JASON
LEOPOLD.
NOW, IN 2006, THIS SO-CALLED
REPORTER, WELL THE COLUMBIA
JOURNALISM REVIEW ALL BUT
PRETTY MUCH CALLED HIM A
LIAR.
THE REVIEW WROTE THAT HE
WOULD GET STORIES COMPLETELY
WRONG.
WE KNEW THAT TODAY.
AND, QUOTE:  EVEN MAKE UP
STUFF WITH STORIES THAT HAD
NO SOURCES AT ALL.
WELL, IT LOOKS LIKE HE HAS
DONE IT AGAIN.
ALL IN A BLATANT EFFORT TO
DESTROY PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IT'S SAD.
BUT, WHAT IS EVEN REALLY
WORSE, EVEN FAKE NEWS CNN
AND CONSPIRACY TV, MSNBC,
THEY GO WITH THE STORY BUT
THEY ARE CONSTANTLY -- THEY
PUT IN THE CAVEAT OVER AND
OVER AGAIN.
THIS IS WHAT WE HEARD ALL
DAY LONG.
UNVERIFIED.
BUT IF IT'S TRUE, WITH A
LEVEL OF HYSTERIA AND
EXCITEMENT, AND THEN, OF
COURSE, HOW MANY TIMES HAVE
THEY MENTIONED IMPEACHMENT?
LOOK AT EXACTLY WHAT I MEAN.
>> A STORY WHICH HAS NOT
BEEN CONFIRMED BY NBC NEWS.
>> WE SHOULD NOTE CNN HAS
NOT INDEPENDENTLY CONFIRMED
BUZZFEED'S REPORTING NOR,
FOR THAT MATTER HAS ANYONE
ELSE.
>> AN EXPLOSIVE NEW REPORT
THAT, IF TRUE,.
>> IF IT'S TRUE.
>> IF TRUE.
>> IF YOU BELIEVE THE
REPORTING.
>> IF THIS IS CONFIRMED.
>> IF ALL OF THIS IS TRUE.
>> IF TRUE.
>> WE DON'T HAVE SOURCING
THAT CONFIRMS THIS STORY BUT
WE'RE NOT GETTING STEERED
OFF OF IT.
>> WE DON'T KNOW FOR SURE.
YOU SAID YOU COULDN'T
CORROBORATE THIS.
>> IF TRUE.
THIS IS POTENTIALLY VERY BIG
DEVELOPMENT.
>> IF IT'S TRUE.
>> Sean: , IF IF, IF, IF
TRUE.
NOW, DESPITE ALL THESE RED
FLAGS, MANY OTHERS IN THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA
BREATHLESSLY, HYSTERICALLY
PUSHING THIS FAKE, FIRESTONE
FRAUD LENGTH
PHAUD LENGTH
PHOND LENGTH
PHONY LENGTH
PHONYFRENGTH
PHONYFRAUGTH
PHONYFRAUDUH
PHONYFRAUDULENT AND OF COURSE
PREDICTING TRUMP'S IMMINENT
IMPEACHMENT AS THEY ALWAYS
DO FOR TWO YEARS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> STILL NO REACTION THIS
MORNING FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP
REPORT TIES HIM DIRECTLY TO
THE VERY SAME OFFENSE FOR
WHICH THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES MOVED TO
IMPEACH RICHARD NIXON.
>> IF TRUE, HE WOULD BE
GUILTY OF SUBBOARDING PURGE
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE
SEEMENTSDZ SEEMS LIKE
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
EXACTLY KIND OF THING THAT
DROVE RICHARD NIXON FROM
OFFICE.
THIS REPORT IS A HUGE DEAL.
AND, YOU KNOW, THIS IS --
THESE ARE VERY CREDIBLE
REPORTERS.
WE ARE DEEP IN THE REALM NOW
OF CREDIBLY IMPEACHABLE
OFFENSES.
>> THERE ARE AN AWFUL LOT OF
SIMILARITIES.
A COUPLE OF ARTICLES OF
IMPEACHMENT AGAINST NIXON
AND THE ELEMENTS OF THIS
STORY.
>> IMPEACHMENT WOULD
ACTUALLY ALLOW HIM TO AT
LEAST DO WHAT HE LOVES WHICH
IS TO BE AND PRETEND HE IS
THE VICTIM AND THE DEMOCRATS
ARE THIS AND THAT BUT AT THE
END OF THE DAY, I THINK THE
IMPEACHMENT PROCESS, IF
THERE ARE, YOU KNOW, THIS
THESE FACTS ARE CORROBORATED
IN TODAY'S REPORT, I
ACTUALLY JUST DON'T SEE HOW
CONGRESS CAN DO ANYTHING
ELSE.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
YOU WOULD THINK BY NOW THE
SO-CALLED JOURNALISTS IN THE
ECHO CHAMBER, THE EXTENSION
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
WOULD HAVE LEARNED THEIR
LESSON.
THEY HAVE BEEN BURN SOD MANY
TIMES BEFORE IN THE LAST TWO
YEARS.
REMEMBER, THE SHORT LIFE
HYSTERIA ABOUT NPR FAKE DON
JR. STORY.
REMEMBER THE HYPE
SURROUNDING MICHAEL COHEN
SECRET PROM TRIP IT NEVER
HAPPENED.
THE GUARDIAN'S REPORTING
ABOUT PAUL MANAFORT OR WHEN
CNN FAKE NEWS STAFFERS WERE
FORCED TO RESIGN AFTER
REPORTING FAKE NEWS ABOUT
OUR FRIEND ANTHONY
SCARAMUCCI.
LOOK AT THE LIST WE HAVE
COMPILED.
FAKE STORY AFTER FAKE STORY.
NOW, "THE WASHINGTON
EXAMINER" PUT THIS TOGETHER.
47 PRINTED PAGES FOR ONE
YEAR ALONE AGAINST DONALD
TRUMP OF FAKE NEWS THAT THEY
BREATHLESSLY REPORT.
UNBRIDLED.
REMEMBER WHAT I SAID AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE YEAR HATRED
OF THE PRESIDENT.
SO MANY FORCED CORRECTIONS.
BUT THEN THEY JUST KEEP
DOING IT AGAIN AND AGAIN.
HOW MANY ANONYMOUS SOURCES HEARS
HOW MANY ANONYMOUS SOURCES HEARY
HOW MANY ANONYMOUS SOURCES HEAR,
RUMORS, DO YOU THINK ANY OF
THIS IS GOOD FOR THE
COUNTRY?
ARE THEY LOOKING OUT FOR
YOUR SECURITY?
, THE ECONOMY, THE BETTER
JOB FOR YOUR CHILDREN?
A BETTER FUTURE FOR OUR
GRAND KIDS?
YOU KNOW WHAT?
RIGHT NOW ONE MORE NOTCH IN
THE OLD FAKE NEWS BELT.
IT IS BEYOND DISGUSTING.
YOU JUST SAW IT ALL, ALL
DAY, PEOPLE SCREAMING
IMPEACH, IMPEACH, IMPEACH.
THIS IS ALL THE HATE THAT WE
GET AS I HAVE BEEN SAYING
EVERY SECOND, EVERY MINUTE,
EVERY HOUR OF EVERY DAY FROM
THE DEMOCRATS.
THE HATE TRUMP PRESS AND, OF
COURSE, THE DEEP STATE.
NOW, ALL OF A SUDDEN TODAY
THE HATE TRUMP MEDIA WAS
CONCERNED ABOUT OBSTRUCTION
OF JUSTICE.
THAT'S WHAT THEY WANTED YOU
TO BELIEVE TODAY.
BUT THEY ARE THE SAME PEOPLE
WHO GAVE HILLARY CLINTON A
PASS.
IT'S BEEN ALMOST TWO
STRAIGHT YEARS OF NEVER
ENDING, CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
FAKE NEWS HATRED.
NOT JUST FOR THE PRESIDENT
THOUGH, BUT ALSO FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT VOTED FOR THIS
PRESIDENT.
I HAVE SAID IT SINCE 2007
AND 2008.
JOURNALISM IN AMERICA IS
DEAD.
AND IT IS BURIED.
AND DRIVEN BY AN
UNPRECEDENTED PATHOLOGICAL
HATRED FOR THE PRESIDENT.
THE BIAS IN THIS COUNTRY HAS
BECOME MORE IMPORTANT THAN
WHAT IS FACT AND WHAT IS
REPORTING, RUMOR IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN SOURCES, AS
RECKLESS SPECULATION RULES
THE DAY.
WE TOLD YOU AT THE BEGINNING
OF THE YEAR ON THIS PROGRAM.
WE WILL ALWAYS FIGHT BACK.
WE WANT THE COUNTRY TO BE
SAFER, MORE SECURE.
WE WANT EVERY AMERICAN
FAMILY PROSPEROUS AND WE ARE
GOING TO LOOK OUT FOR YOU,
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, BECAUSE
YOU DESERVE BETTER THAN WHAT
THE REST OF THE MEDIA IS
OFFERING.
WHICH IS WHY WE ACTUALLY
COVER, FOR EXAMPLE, THE
CRISIS AT OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER.
NOW, WHEN THE FAKE NEWS
INDUSTRY IS TOO BUSY WITH
THEIR FAKE STORIES AND
CONSPIRACY THEORIES ABOUT
THE PRESIDENT, WELL, TODAY,
NEARLY 400 MIGRANTS WERE
APPREHENDED BY BORDER PATROL
AT ONCE AFTER ALL CROSSING
ILLEGALLY.
THE SITUATION IS URGENT.
IT SERIOUS.
YET, SOMEONE STILL NEEDS TO
REMIND THE SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE, NANCY PELOSI, THAT
WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF A
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN.
HER DETACHMENT AND HEIR
INDIFFERENCE, HER LACK OF
SELF-AWARENESS IS BEYOND
SHOCKING.
TODAY SPEAKER PELOSI AND
OTHER TOP DEMOCRATS ONCE
AGAIN TRIED TO SKIP OUT OF
TOWN A WEEK LONG
INTERNATIONAL EXCURSION
WHICH WOULD HAVE GUARANTEED
THE FURLOUGHED EMPLOYEES
SOME 800,000 OF THEM DON'T
GET PAID AGAIN.
NOW, THIS TIME THEY WERE
GOING TO TAKE A COMMERCIAL
PLANE JUST FOR SHOW AFTER
THE PRESIDENT FOILED HER
FIRST ATTEMPT TO LEAVE THE
COUNTRY ON YOUR DIME IN A
U.S. MILITARY AIRCRAFT.
BUT NOW, AFTER HER NEW PLAN
RELEASED SPARKING SECURITY
CONCERNS PELOSI'S OVERSEAS
VOYAGE HAS ONCE AGAIN BEEN
POSTPONED INDEFINITELY.
ENOUGH TO, MAYBE SHE WILL
ACCEPT WHAT IS THE
PRESIDENT'S DAILY INVITATION
TO NEGOTIATE.
SAFETY, SECURITY, AND OUR
COUNTRY.
AND THE GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN.
SPOKESPERSON FOR THE SPEAKER
ACTUALLY BLAMED THE
PRESIDENT.
OF COURSE, FORT LEAK.
AN ALLEGATION THE WHITE
HOUSE HAS CALLED A FLAT OUT
LIE.
SO, HERE WE ARE TODAY, 28
DAYS INTO A GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN AND THE SPEAKER OF
THE U.S. HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES, THE MOST
POWERFUL DEMOCRAT IN THE
COUNTRY, IS TRYING
DESPERATELY, ONCE AGAIN, TO
LEAVE TOWN.
REFUSING TO NEGOTIATE YET
AGAIN.
REMEMBER, SHE TOOK HER
LENGTHY TROPICAL VACATION AT
THE BEGINNING OF THE
SHUTDOWN.
DOZENS OF OTHER DEMOCRATS,
OH, THEY HAD A LUXURIOUS
VACATION PAID FOR BY
LOBBYISTS IN A CHARTERED
AIRCRAFT TO PUERTO RICO.
WHILE PELOSI AND SCHUMER
SENT AIDES TO NEGOTIATE WITH
THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES?
INSTEAD OF HELPING THE
FURLOUGHED EMPLOYEES AND
CREATING MORE SECURITY THAT
THEY DID SUPPORT FOUR YEARS
AGO?
SO, TONIGHT WE HAVE GOT TO
ASK SOME REALLY IMPORTANT
OBVIOUS QUESTIONS.
DOES SPEAKER PELOSI REALLY
WANT AN ANSWER SOLUTION.
IS SHE REALLY WORKING AT
ALL?
IS SHE NOW COMPROMISED BY
THE RADICAL LEFT WING OF HER
PARTY AND SCARED TO DEATH TO
EVEN TALK TO THE PRESIDENT?
DOES SHE CARE ABOUT THE 90%
OF HEROIN IN THIS COUNTRY
COMING ACROSS OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER?
OR THE GANGS OR THE CARTELS
OR THE HUMAN TRAFFICKING?
SHE WON'T EVEN TALK TO THE
ANGEL MOMS AND DADS THAT
WENT OUTSIDE HER OFFICE THIS
WEEK THAT HAVE LOST THEIR
CHILDREN BECAUSE OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION?
NOW, THE PRESIDENT, HE
DIDN'T GO ON VACATION.
HE HAS BEEN HERE THE WHOLE
TIME INVITING DEMOCRATS
EVERY DAY.
HE IS TRYING TO FULFILL NOT
ONLY A CAMPAIGN PROMISE BUT
HE IS TRYING TO KEEP THE
COUNTRY SAFE.
TRYING TO PREVENT THE DRUGS
FROM COMING INTO THE
COUNTRY.
REMEMBER, MAYBE THE 1% OR 2%
OF THOSE PEOPLE THAT ENTER
THE COUNTRY ILLEGALLY, THEY
ARE CRIMINALS AND MURDERS
HAVE HAPPENED AND WORSE.
AND, YOU KNOW, HOW MANY
SEXUAL ASSAULTS?
HOW MANY VIOLENT ASSAULTS?
NOW, THE PRESIDENT TWEETED
TODAY, I WILL BE MAKING A
MAJOR ANNOUNCEMENT
CONCERNING THE HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS ON OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER.
AND THE SHUTDOWN TOMORROW
AFTERNOON AT 3:00 P.M. LIVE
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE.
OH, HE IS WORKING ON
SATURDAY.
IN THE MEANTIME, PRESIDENT
TRUMP IS READY, WILL, ABLE
TO NEGOTIATE AND HAS BEEN
SINCE DAY ONE OF THE
SHUTDOWN.
DEMOCRATS HAVE OFFERED
NOTHING EXCEPT A DOLLAR.
NO NEGOTIATIONS, NO
COMPROMISE.
NO TIME WITH THE PRESIDENT.
THEY JUST SIT BACK AND DO
NOTHING.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEES ARE NOT
RECEIVING THEIR PAY.
THE SPEAKER IS HAVING A
MELTDOWN ABOUT NOT GETTING
TO TAKE A GOVERNMENT FUNDED
TRIP ON YOUR DIME.
AND EVEN WORSE, THOUSANDS OF
LIVES HAVE BEEN LOST,
THOUSANDS MORE DEVASTATED BY
THE FLOW OF ILLEGAL DRUGS,
HUMAN TRAFFICKING, THE
OPIOID CRISIS.
THE GANG ACTIVITY ACROSS THE
SOUTHERN BORDER AND NANCY
PELOSI COMPLAINING ABOUT
HAVING TO POSTPONE A
GOVERNMENT-FUNDED TRIP.
THAT'S WHERE HER MIND IS
TONIGHT.
FEAR NOT, LET NOT YOUR HEART
BE TROUBLED.
SPEAKER PELOSI, WHILE
AMERICANS SUFFER, WHILE
WE'RE NOT SAFER, WELL, YOUR
CLOSE FRIENDS IN THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA,THEY ARE
CHEERING YOU EVERY STEP OF
THE WAY.
YOU KNOW, JUST LIKE LAST
WEEK MANUFACTURED CRISIS.
DEMOCRATS SAY IT THE MEDIA
SAYS IT THEY ARE LIKE TIED
AT THE HIP.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP IS COMING
FACE TO FACE WITH THE
REALITY OPPOSITION PARTY
CONTROLLING THE HOUSE.
THIS MORNING HOUSE SPEAKER
NANCY PELOSI THREW HIM A
HARD FAST BALL.
>> SPEAKER PELOSI PLAYING
HARD BALL.
>> YOU COULD SAY SHE IS
PLAYING HARD BALL.
>> HOUSE SPEAKER PELOSI
FLEXING HER CONSTITUTIONAL
MUSCLE.
>> SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE
NANCY PELOSI IS FLEXING HER
MUSCLES.
>> A BOLD POWER PLAY THE
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE TONIGHT
IS SENDED A POINTED MESSAGE
TO PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> IT IS A POWER PLAY AND
NANCY PELOSI IS REVEALING
THAT SHE HAS A PH.D. IN
NEEDLING PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> SHE KNOWS WHERE TO GO
EXACTLY WHERE TO HURT HIM
WHERE IT HURTS.
>> THIS IS POLITICAL GENIUS.
I GIVE NANCY PELOSI CREDIT
FOR HER POLITICAL SENSE.
>> IT'S KINDS OF BAD ASS
FROM NANCY PELOSI.
SHE WAS SHOWING THAT SHE IS
IN CHARGE.
>> NANCY PELOSI, I MEAN,
WHAT A BAD ASS.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW WHAT?
MAYBE IT'S TIME FOR THE
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE TO
ACTUALLY START LISTENING
TOUT AMERICAN PEOPLE.
START SOLVING PROBLEMS.
STOP APPEALING TO YOUR
RADICAL BASE.
IN OTHER WORDS, REALLY
SIMPLY, YOU NEED TO DO YOUR
JOB.
THE PRESIDENT, HIS DOOR IS
WIDE OPEN.
GO NEGOTIATE A DEAL.
MAYBE YOU WILL GET SOME OF
THE THINGS YOU SAY YOU WANT.
SECURE THE BORDERS, REOPEN
THE GOVERNMENT.
AND FOR GOODNESS SAKES GET
OUT OF YOUR I'VE RIFF TOWER.
IF NOT THE PRESIDENT HE WILL
DO IT WITHOUT YOU.
LET'S NOT LOSE SIGHT OF THE
FACT THAT WHAT WE'RE
FIGHTING FOR DON'T BE FOOLED
BY ALL THE TRUMP HATERS, THE
CRISIS AT THE SOUTHERN
BORDER IS NOT MANUFACTURED.
IN FACT, AS CAN YOU SEE A
BRAND NEW MIGRANT CARAVAN
MARCHING TOWARD OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER AS WE SPEAK.
EARLIER TODAY THOUSANDS OF
MIGRANTS POURED INTO
SOUTHERN MEXICO AFTER
THORTSDZ THERE JUST LEFT THE
GATES AT THE BORDER WIDE
OPEN.
MEXICAN BORDER GUARDS DIDN'T
SHOW UP UNTIL SUNRISE
ACTUALLY AFTER SUNRISE.
SO NOW WHILE MEXICO MAY BE
EMBRACING OPEN BORDERS, OF
THE PRESIDENT IS CONTINUING
TO STAND STRONG, STAY ON THE
JOB, WAITING TO NEGOTIATE,
WAITING TO KEEP HIS PROMISE
TO SECURE THE BORDER OF THIS
COUNTRY.
THIS IS ABOUT LIFE AND
DEATH.
HE TWEETED TODAY, QUOTE:
ANOTHER BIG CARAVAN IS
HEADING OUR WAY.
VERY HARD TO STOP WITHOUT A
WALL.
AND THE FACT IS WE HAVE AN
ACTUAL CRISIS ON OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
JUST LOOK AT THIS VIDEO FROM
BORDER PATROL.
AND THE HUMA SECTOR IN
ARIZONA WHERE NEARLY 400
MIGRANTS 57 PREHAD ENDED AT
ONCE TODAY AFTER CROSSING
ILLEGALLY.
THAT IS NOT MANUFACTURED.
THAT IS THE REALITY.
WE NEED THESE PHYSICAL
BARRIERS, WHICH ARE
EFFECTIVE, ALL ACLOSE CROSS
THE WORLD.
REMEMBER YESTERDAY, ALSO IN
ARIZONA A GROW UP OF
MIGRANTS WERE CAUGHT TRYING
TO TUNNEL UNDER A WALL.
BUT, BECAUSE THERE WAS A
WALL, THEY COULDN'T JUST
WALK ACROSS AND FLEE LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
AND ONCE THEY TUNNELED
THROUGH, THEY WERE PROMPTLY
CAUGHT.
OH, THE WALL WORKS.
NOW, DON'T EXPECT TO HEAR
ANY OF THIS FROM THE HATE
TRUMP MEDIA AS YOU CAN SEE
FROM TONIGHT'S BUZZFEED HUGE
MASSIVE EMBARRASSMENT THE
FAKE NEWS EPIDEMIC HAS NEVER
BEEN WORSE.
BY THE WAY, IT ALL SURROUNDS
ONE THING.
THEIR HATRED OF ALL THINGS
DONALD TRUMP.
AND BY THE WAY, TRUMP
SUPPORTERS.
AND THAT'S WHY THEY ARE ALL
COMPLETELY IGNORED WHAT WAS
MAJOR NEWS THAT WE HAD THIS
WEEK ABOUT THE DEEP STATE,
ABOUT FISA ABUSE.
AND MEANWHILE WE HAVE BEEN
ONE OF THE ONLY PROGRAMS
REPORTING THESE LATEST
DEVELOPMENTS, LATEST,
NEEDLESS TO SAY, IT WAS A
BAD WEEK FOR SOME OF THOSE
EMBEDDED INSIDE OF OUR
GOVERNMENT THAT DON'T LIKE
THE PRESIDENT.
WE LEARNED UNDER JAMES
COMEY'S WATCH IS GENERAL
COUNSEL WE LEARNED THIS WEEK
JAMES BAKER IS NOW UNDER A
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION.
AND ACCORDING TO JOHN
SOLOMON'S REPORTING AND
DON'T FORGET ANDREW MCCABE,
HIS DEPUTY, IS ALSO UNDER A
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION.
AND JOHN SOLOMON POINTING
OUT THAT JAMES COMEY AND
OTHERS WERE ALL BRIEFED
ABOUT THE PHONY DOSSIER BACK
IN AUGUST.
THEY WERE TOLD BY BRUCE OHR,
ACCORDING TO HIS SWORN
TESTIMONY THAT WE ONLY GOT
THIS WEEK THEN HE TOLD ALL
OF THEM IN THE FBI, ALL OF
THEM IN THE STATE
DEPARTMENT, OH, HILLARY PAID
FOR IT.
AND CHRISTOPHER STEELE HATES
THE PRESIDENT, OH, AND, BY
THE WAY, THEY PUT THIS THING
TOGETHER AND I WOULDN'T
TRUST IT.
BUT IN SPITE OF THAT WARNING
HE WENT AHEAD ANYWAY.
AS THE GRAMLY GRAHAM MEMO
POINTED OUT, THE BULK OF
INFORMATION WAS USED IN THE
FISA WARRANT.
THAT WOULD BE A CONSPIRACY
TO COMMIT A FRAUDS AGAINST
THE COURT.
WE ALSO KNOW ANDREW WISEMAN
AND ANOTHER MUELLER
INVESTIGATOR, THEY WERE ALSO
BRIEFED ON THESE WARNINGS
THINK KNEW IT WAS BIASED AND
UNVERIFIED.
HILLARY PAID FOR LIES TO
INFLUENCE THE 2016 ELECTION.
STILL, MUELLER USED IT AS A
BASIS OF HIS INVESTIGATION
BUT NEVER INVESTIGATED
HILLARY WHO BOUGHT IT.
NOW, WE HAVE BEEN WARNING
YOU FOR MONTHS, THIS IS THE
BIGGEST ABUSE OF POWER
CORRUPTION SCANDAL IN MODERN
AMERICAN HISTORY.